là messieurs bonsoir 9 9 24 60
y at il un drame plus éprouvant pour des
parents que de vivre la perte d'un
enfant et de surcroît par suicide
il y aura deux ans mercredi thomas
taillefer le fils de l'homme d'affaires
alexandre taillefer s'est enlevé la vie
il souffrait de cyber dépendance et
depuis alexandre taillefer temps de
donner un sens à cette épreuve
une quête qui est au coeur du
documentaire intitulé by cyber
dépendance mal être des adolescents
suicide des sujets difficiles à aborder
avec les principaux intéressés voici un
extrait du documentaire salut
qui ici jouent aux jeux vidéo plus que
son inventeur semaine le vélo mais 21
semaines pointant ce moment tout le
monde qui joue au moins 25 heures par
semaine
ce ça fait à peu près 7 à peu près trois
heures et demie par jour qui vont jouer
plus que mettons à cinq heures par jour
en moyenne 35 heures semaine
ouais c'est ça fait du monde qui va
jouer on va y aller pour la vraie le 50
heures semaine alors l'on est à un gros
coup au moins dix heures par jour qui se
lève le matin la première chose qui fait
le cd livres et jeux vidéo
[Musique]
d'autre part maintenant cinq ans que je
dois mettre environ 35 14 demain est ce
que tu faisais cette chaîne at on
seulement ça va mais tant que tu es dans
un café comme ça dans le café c'est un
mec mars apprend que je suis si oui
c'est le fun est seul chez jules va
souvent genre t'es plus concentré mais
en même temps ils montrent le lien
social corruption menées en ce sens mais
parce que les gens ici qui ont déjà fait
une tentative de suicide
[Musique]
je
je vous demander d'enlever vos écouteurs
je vous racontais une seconde ce
documentaire bail qui sera diffusé
demain soir à 21h sur radio canada sur
le web est également vous pourrez suivre
une table ronde de catherine perrin la
première chaîne radio donc à 22h mais
comment donc peut-on aider ces jeunes
souvent isolés valorisé par le jeu vidéo
quel constat attire alexandre taillefer
pendant ce tournage du documentaire je
lui ai parlé un petit peu plus tôt
alexandra fr bonsoir bienvenue à 24,60
j'aurais aimé vous parler dans d'autres
circonstances mais ce soir j'accueille
un père et je sais qu'une mère
endeuillée une soeur endeuillées pour la
mort de thomas se fera deux ans mercredi
et vous êtes parti en quête de
compréhension dans le but de de faire en
sorte que tous les thomas soit épargnée
alors que votre fils ne l'a pas été
c'est un peu la démarche que vous allez
faire aussi une démarche quand c'est
arrivé j'ai j'ai beaucoup réfléchi à ce
que je pouvais tirer comme le centre et
commencent que j'étais en mesure de
faire une différence pour les autres
thomas du monde
je pense que ça va être très difficile
d'éliminer le suicide je pense que c'est
impossible
ça sera tout le temps malheureusement
une alternative pour certaines personnes
qui souffrent trou mais on est capable
aujourd'hui de faire de grands efforts
surtout auprès des jeunes je pense alors
ses documentaires love a diffusé demain
soir 21h sur nos ondes
tout à l'heure je vais pouvoir dire
monsieur vous pouvez l'écouter sur
toutes les plateformes catherine perrin
la même table ronde à la radio après
mais ensemble alexandre taillefer on va
écouter un court extrait de ce
documentaire absolument
va bouleverser en percutant est
essentiel du couple comment envoyer un
message un des gars qui lui plus connus
tissot twitch l'appel à l'aide d'outils
ou expliqué clairement que j'ai
l'intention de se suicider ça a été fait
au mois de mai puis mon fils s'est
suicidé le 6 décembre pendant six mois
on n'a pas su qu'il y avait ses
intentions le toit tout avait écrit une
lettre puis ça a été ça a déclenché tout
un processus long et ont amené à
sainte-justine d'aller voir des
spécialistes
j'ai juste plus capable c'est quand il y
avait quelque chose que je suis en train
de vivre que je me débarrasse
je sais que c'est quelque chose de très
difficile
est ce que tu me permettrai de l'aller
où
[Musique]
une
bon
où
c'est extrêmement personnel je pense
qu'on a besoin de lire ça aux gens dit
toi par contre que mon fils la seule
chose qui me laissez moi c'est bye
et
moi jamais dit avant de partir comme tu
fais dans cette ligue look est que tu
aimes dit pas là
alexandre taillefer ce jeune homme loïc
c'est un dites moi que vous voulez
sauver d'une certaine manière avec ce
documentaire le résultat dans la main
comme ça un jeune homme maintenant à 18
ans et que qui je parle fréquemment un
petit garçon intelligent articulé avec
des patients importante mais qui a des
enjeux c'est clair il laisse faire de
cyberdépendance on voit aujourd'hui son
périple au sein d'un centre de désintox
c'est un centre qui ressemble beaucoup à
un centre en fait ils vont traiter aussi
des gens qui souffrent de toxicomanie
mais souvent ils traitent aujourd'hui la
cyberdépendance un peu de la même façon
ça s'appelle le grand chemin de grand
chemin d'après on découvre cette
ressource là indispensable mais ça
commence aussi le jour où on sort d'une
ressource comme celle là il faut pas
s'arrêter en chemin
exactement c'est un combat qui peut
durer très longtemps et quand on a 18
ans quand les hormones se développe le
lobe frontal est pas encore entièrement
en place on découvre sa sexualité
c'est des moments difficiles pour de
jong à son jeune fille alors
effectivement ça prend c'est un travail
de tous les instants
on va parler tibet pendant un instant
mais dans cet extrait il ya aussi ce qui
se dégage votre désir de comprendre la
détresse que plus la [ __ ] et oman la
détresse que pu habiter le hic est qu'il
habite peut-être encore on sait pas mais
aussi pourquoi cette détresse le
s'installer c'est le lien vous voulez
faire avec la cyberdépendance exact en
fait on a des musées aujourd'hui à
comprendre si le cyber dépendance et
l'oeuf ou la poule
je pense qu'il ya certainement des
conditions qui font que les gens vont
aller se réfugier dans les jeux vidéo
ceci dit quand on commence à passer trop
de temps devant les jeux vidéo
quand on commence à être déconnecté de
la réalité a préféré dans un monde
virtuel avoir plus d'amis en ligne que
dans le vrai monde
il ya des questions qui doivent se poser
quand on a un enjeu d'hygiène quand on a
un enjeu de ponctualité quand on se
couche trop tard on est fatigué et la
première chose qu'on fait en seulement
le matin s'est joué à des jeux
il faut comprendre quel impact est ce
que ce monde ne peut avoir sur
la psychologie des gens qui c'est une
grande illusion que ce bien-être de
vivre devant l'écran à côté du mal de
vivre dans la réalité tout à fait rien
en jeu par la suite naturellement de
sociabilisation qui s'installe parce que
la capacité rsa d'avoir des relations
saines réel avec d'autres êtres humains
quand on est à leurs côtés
ça se complexifie parce que le jeune les
jeunes que vous avez rencontré existence
je te valoriser dans nos jeux vidéo je
peux contester je suis méchant
d'interaction il n'y a pas de mieux à
dire qu'il n'ya pas je pas juger tout
les tout ce qu'il fait quand même deux
villes te faire et ce à un très grand
impact parce que quand on connaît le
succès sur des jeux vidéo qu'on était
adulé par d'autres joueurs qui ont fait
partie d'une équipe quand on sort de
l'eau etc on a une faible estime de soi
s'entraîne actuellement des enjeux
importants
il doit même extrait convient de voir
sur ce film d'une heure de l'est à
chaque seconde est important que chaque
année d'importants vous évoquez le nom
d'un site twitch dont on n'apprend pas
plusieurs d'entre nous l'existence ou
votre fils allait communiquer avec ces
gens là et c'est à eux cette société là
qu'il a confié ses idées suicidaires qui
nous on sait depuis longtemps
oui il a envoyé un courriel très clair
aux mots demi dans lequel le mot un
suicide de revient dans lequel il
partage ses peines qui partagent ces
enjeux et c'est ce courriel a été
renvoyé à la même personne au mois de
juin notamment s'est enlevé la vie au
mois de décembre est le jour où il s'est
enlevé la vie il a envoyé des messages
encore une fois sur la plateforme twitch
les messages très clairs
il a donné trois mille cinq cents d'or à
des gens qui sont sur cette plateforme
là ils envoient il envoyer des messages
qui ne le laissait place à aucune
imagination et puis ce qui vous met sans
doute en colère je ne sais pas je peux
porter un jugement sur le sentiment que
vous habite la face at which may ce site
était capable de recevoir l'argent
mais incapables de répondre aux signes
de détresse dos thomas comme à vous
appelle vous même vous avez tenté ce
poste depuis le documentaire vous avez
des échanges directs avec les jaunes ce
site là on a à la base vous lui envoyez
une lettre d'avocat pour les
responsabiliser et mon épouse choisi de
ne pas aller se battre on a voulu
essayer d'établir un dialogue c'est ce
qu'on a tenté de faire à plusieurs
reprises des dizaines de fois et ces
gens là ont refusé de nous rencontrer et
on sait aujourd'hui que twitch est un
endroit où se propage ce genre de
message
ils ce sont des cordes citoyen
corporatif qui ne prennent pas leurs
responsabilités
d'autres le font facebook a annoncé il
ya une semaine environ qu'il mettait en
place des outils pour détecter des
envies suicidaires mais dans le code
switch je dois vous avouer que je suis
extrêmement vous avez dit fâché le mot
est faible jeu indigne et je trouve
inacceptable qu'une entreprise comme ça
qui accueille des jeunes qui souffrent
le cyber dépendance ne prennent pas ces
responsables dans le film que vous êtes
en mode solution vous réussissez la
communauté technologique et vous allez
même faire un projet pilote au collège
durocher pour installer un portail pour
les jeunes est ce que il donc l'espoir
de ce côté là de pouvoir aller là où les
jeunes sont parce que dans le fond des
douleurs que vous avez c'est ce que je
comprends d'un excès qu'on a vu c'est
pourquoi les enfants ont des parents
pour que les enfants s'adresse pas à
nous pour comme killer détresse puis un
jeune que vous eeb un énorme pot parents
qu'on va dire ça donc on vole on veux
pas les décevoir
c'est un moment très fort le
documentaire et 7 cette relation là je
peux pas faire autrement penser à mes
propres 14 15 16 ans le dialogue est pas
toujours simple entre des parents et des
adolescents aujourd'hui je voudrais que
j'étais peut-être coupable à 75% de ski
de ça quand j'étais plus jeune mais
c'est clair que c'est un enjeu important
de communication entre parents enfants
d'une communication intergénérationnelle
et j'espère que les familles seront
nombreuses
la regarder le documentaire ensemble les
parents les enfants pour qu'un dialogue
et puis ça par la suite s'établir et que
si des jeunes ont ce genre dans villa ou
ont des enjeux de santé mentale qu'ils
en parlent parce que de l'aide est
disponible
quand on parle de santé mentale et
j'emprunte que les mots à une ancienne
collègue est une amie qui paraît
toujours des victimes de ces civière
invisible parce que le centre de kung fu
nécessairement au fil des années
plusieurs entrevues nous amener à
questionner interroger des gens sur ce
qu'on a assez de soins par ses soins
c'est une enfant pauvre du système de
santé ce qui semble se confirmer
cela dit vous êtes alexandre taillefer
on est entrepreneur florissant et leur
vous avez eu accès à dr barrette on le
voit dans le documentaire puis là il ya
no 124 jours 35 millions de la
psychothérapie 15 millions pour les
jeunes il y aurait pas fait ça pour
d'autres parce que c'était ce que vous
mettez votre notoriété au service de la
santé mentale d'un pull but mais je
pense que il ya aujourd'hui plus en plus
de d'état qui mettra en place qui met en
place des solutions comme par exemple
l'angleterre qui a mis en place un
problème s'appelle nice qui est
exactement le même problème que le
gouvernement a choisi d'implanter ici au
québec et qui a démontré un retour sur
investissement fantastique alors j'ose
croire que c'était quelque chose qui
était en branle que les cris des
psychologues des psychiatres commencé à
se faire entendre
vous avez parlé d'enfants pauvres c'est
tout à fait ça on est aujourd'hui dans
une situation où un peu plus de 2% nos
budgets de santé est alloué à la santé
mentale
c'est beaucoup trop peu on sait à quel
point est-ce que c'est le meilleur
investissement qu'une société peut faire
parce qu'on se dit depuis des années
qu'on n'avait pas de compressions mes
docteurs et guarda la président de
l'association depuis quatre à visiter
les locaux où le travail paie vous êtes
le père du délit important des délits
qui soigne des personnes en situation de
crise à les opus et lila alors c'est
civière invisible là on espère qu'elle
ce sont plus en plus visible et c'est un
peu un sens à quoi sert ce documentaire
je dois saluer le travail de déferlante
est pas du temps mais aussi le travail
de radio canada que mis toute son
énergie derrière la promotion d'un
documentaire sur un sujet difficile y
ait vraiment c'est quelque chose qui je
pense va réussir à faire changer encore
davantage les chaumes et ce parce que
vous avez eu aussi eu le courage de vous
mettre en situation de douleur et de
peine est devenu pour transformer sa
pour la prévention au fond je pense que
des traitements le volet qui très
personnelle le volet qui est très
émotionnel aussi est un vecteur
important de transmission de ce message
puis ce qui est important c'est que
cette pensée aussi que pour thomas vous
aviez déployer sortes de démarches pour
lui venir en aide
ouais on aura encore beaucoup de monde
et déjà santé social des psychiatres des
psychologues et jamais le mot suicide
n'a été prononcée malgré le fait qu'on
il a été dans une situation presque
psychotique way dans l'idaho modja alors
c'est un on espère que ça va permettre à
d'autres d'avoir une conclusion plus
heureuse
est ce que ça vous a aidé de le faire à
votre épouse est à vous pour votre fille
et puis quand je vois la réaction des
gens quand je vois le nombre de messages
que je reçois de familles qui ont vécu
quelque chose de semblable de gens qui
souffrent de problèmes et qui
aujourd'hui s'ouvre davantage
je le vois un peu comme un baume sur une
plaie qui est qui se refermera pas mais
qui peut peut-être servir à quelque
chose alors tant mieux la courte
victoire sera transformé en une grande
l'expérience aussi espérons le
merci donc